bismillah al hamdulillah assalamu
alaikum which is the greeting of peace
peace be unto you and Ramadan five
pillars of Islam submission to the will
of God one is that you worship none but
the creator of the heavens and earth and
not his creation and you accept Muhammad
is the last and final messenger sent to
mankind which includes Jesus Moses
Abraham they all came with same message
worship the Creator not his creation and
then you agree to pray five times a day
not six five four three or none but five
times a day minimum you connect with
your Creator because you love him he
loves you he's given you everything that
you have and at the end you get Jenna
paradise and you avoid the hellfire
Ramadan that's one of the pillars along
with giving the poor do tax and Hajj
once in your lifetime you're physically
financially able we're going to be
talking about ramadan because it's
ramadan time and some of you are new to
islam and you want to know how you can
do it in the best way what are the
details of ramadan because you don't
want it to pass by and you miss out on
all the blessings and the rewards so
we'll be right back with my next guest
from the TV show let's talk about it
sheikh abdul kareem zaid here on the D
show will be right back
this is the
this is the theme you know this is the
days of the theme you know this is the
thing and welcome back to the d show
we're here with sheikh karim salam
alaikum peace be with you buddy who said
i multiply / like a lady Shakespeare
with you thank you fine time to be to be
with us like a little hill and I'm very
happy to be with you how's your program
going let's talk about it people know
you from there let's talk about it
what's all that about well it's really a
show about question-and-answer were
feeble calling with their questions and
we I try to answer and if I don't know I
tell them I don't know educating the
people yes that's what we're doing today
yeah you hurt me open the show Ramadan
yes it's here and Muslims get excited
about it so there are a lot of people
new Muslims all Muslims they might have
come back to practicing their Dean this
way of life from the crater and now we
want to do things right you want to do
things the right way so we can get all
the reward from this blessed month tell
us a little bit about Ramadan why it's
so special well ramadan is an annual i
would say training camp for the soul for
the soul yes that you get a handle of
yourself once again in a way a loss of
hannah wattana sets the stage for you he
chains the shayateen and the massage it
is filmed are filled with people who
pray people are fasting the spirit of
obedience is out there so that you have
no excuse and the incentive is so
motivating imagine the Prophet
sallallahu ala asylum
he basically indicated three golden
opportunities mon-sol Muhammad Ali email
and artists ever if you observe the
fasting from Adan but with these two
restrictions a man that you believe that
you're a servant of Allah soprano time
that you're not doing it because I'm
strong I'm able to do it rather my
creative my lord when did he disappoint
me and I'm his servant and i love it and
i'm going to say to him Sammy on no upon
I hear and I obey my wrote a man it's
it's a pillar of Islam it's mandatory
and I'm submitting to my Lord and I know
it's all good for me whenever I submit
for a lot of Hannah haha what is heaven
and also seeking the reward of fasting
you cannot imagine the amount of Leawood
that you get out of fasting and maybe
will shed some light on this but with
those two restrictions a loss of hannah
allah will forgive only via sense there
is one too man amara madonna email and
1700 fear allah huma had a momentum who
so ever observes Crean yes a lot of
taraweeh the sala that we pray after
esha again eamon and what is ever we
explained those two with the first
citizen english now again email and
believing believing 87 seeking wanting
the rewards believing in your creator
and watching the reward from strictly
from him that don't say i'm fasting
because i want to be healthy don't see
i'm asking because I'm strong I'm
dieting I'm damaging way no no no even
so our scholars when they defined
fasting in the technical terms they said
abstaining from eating and drinking and
all other things which will invalidate
your fast look at the districts with the
intention of the worship of philosophy
but if you get all these benefits
because we're seeing a modern trend
you'll see many personal trainers and
people who are in the fitness world and
they are recommending too fast
they're recommending that you know this
has such great physical benefits but
along the side we're not doing it for
that but if we get those benefits we're
going to double absolutely well that's
that's we work for a lot yeah and we get
the dunya and we get there we get danica
yeah we work with a lot and we get that
benefits we get the benefits because we
trusted tell us this shake tell it
before we go into the do's and don'ts
because we know that Islam submission to
the will of the Creator is in the Bible
you can see it if you look back to the
first man Adam he submitted to the will
of God he and submit to himself to the
creation but he worshiped God Jesus
worship the Creator he didn't call
people to wash him himself he did islam
he was a Muslim Abraham was not a Jew or
Christian but he was one who submitted
to the will of God he was a Muslim one
who's miserable of that and you'll see
that they were praying and you see these
pillars that we have because some people
think Islam is something that was
brought by Muhammad weren't a fasting
too weren't they doing these things can
you emphasize on this a little bit well
Islam just to throw some basic rules
here is the religion of Islam is made of
belief system dot even the Creed then
the rituals you know the manor manners
the etiquettes of dealing with one
another and then comes in this area the
loose the only thing that changes is the
low phone you just said you just said
some sir I don't want Sharia some people
get scared right now they think the
boogeyman is coming to get up what's
what you would just take a second and
surely there's something there like the
Ten Commandments yes is the divine law
God's law that's it obeying god yes it's
not like some cut your head off I don't
believe prophet he sorry Jesus Jesus
will come back and implement they said
yeah Jesus came with Sharia I mean Moses
came with Sharia and Jesus he commits he
confirmed chidiya God's law and guess
what the greatest long you will come and
implement the show ya muhammad is
amazing see when I when you have open
heart open mind you see these prejudices
will go away continue on so we go back
with this Sharia and transactions
mamanet Allah subhana Allah in the Quran
he stresses that all the messengers they
in to convey Islam but would one man did
that they come with Luke will angel min
come Shira woman had but each messenger
will come with some updates on Mandy to
the loose to meet the challenges of the
time because every messenger comes in a
different time in a different place and
their knowledge before loss of Hana Hana
is eternal so when a lot of Hana Hana
spoke about fasting in the Quran he said
yeah you hella Dina n minus o ye who
believe cote de como si amo can cut evil
and edina minn publikum fasting is
mandated upon bano negatory upon you
like it was obligatory upon those who
came before you this is the crater
speaking yes you're quoting what the
verbatim word of god is this is the
Quran this is the Quran the revelation
now that verse indicates indicates that
fasting was also mandated upon the
people of the book before us the
Christian and the Jews who are known to
us to be Muslims the followers of the
messengers at the time our messenger
sallallahu ala am told us the best of
fasting hieracium see amudha would the
best of fasting is the fastening of
David bra'thid David he used to fast one
day and break fast another day
rasulallah arias LM also told us first
lucia me c'mon see Aniyah he'll get her
at lettuce aha what distinguishes you
from the fasting of the people of the
book before you that when you wake up
for the early morning meal which is so
cool that distinguishes us from their
fasting so all of these are evidence
that they use the fast so we're actually
doing something that the nations before
us used to do it but with one important
difference here which we notice in our
diet and our rituals that we must be
different in the way that we pray in
there is a little variation here and
there that distinguishes the the final
message or the final mandate which came
with mohamed salah salem to the previous
because
muhammad sallallahu ala seldom came with
abrogates what whatever came before it
so the original followers of Jesus peace
be upon the original followers of Moses
that stuck to pure monotheism they
didn't worship God is a trinity no cow
you know I'm intermediary between them
and God just the Creator that just goes
with human nature they were Muslims
because Muslims one who submits to love
God they were Muslim you tell them that
and they fasted prayed so the worship
though this is what what we're talking
about this some foreign that we got some
religion that came from Mars or
something no no it's from the creators
it's in that Dina in the law is the
religion of the side of Allah is alyssa
has been in islam from day one and
whoever comes in at a production with
other religion islam it will not be
exhibition to the will of god yes it's
there isn't it I mean you talk to some
creep we always got to go to break but
hallowed be thy name thy kingdom come
Thy will be done that's it thy will that
means Islam your will means I'm gonna do
what you want me to do God absolute not
follow my desires absolutely and that's
what was thriving Google that's what
we're striving to do this amazing it
made we got to take a break we're going
to get into the fasting from A to Z with
[ __ ] Kareem here on the D show will be
right back the smell out hamdulillah
Salam alaikum peace be with you decir al
hamdulillah Salam alaikum peace be unto
you swallow alhamdulillah Salaam alaikum
bismillah al hamdulillah Salam alaikum
peace be unto you welcome to the Dean
show bismillah al hamdulillah Salam
alaikum peace be with you greetings of
peace to everybody all around the globe
that's tuning in to the Dean shop
who
who show us the way to all the squares
this is the Dean did have a slim this is
the D did hubby
back here on the D show with cher Karim
Karim share tell us now we're time at
the fast we've in the introduction we
talked about the five pillars we talked
about that Islam is not a new way of
life a new religion it's from the
Creator and Muhammad is just a last and
final messenger and Jesus worship God
alone he didn't call people to worship
himself nor did any other other
messengers and they fasted today prayed
and they fasted right to the Creator so
now many new Muslims people are
accepting Islam according to Guinness
Book of World Records the fastest
growing religion in the world right and
it's not just because Muslims I have
more babies some people say it's because
people are using their mind and people
who want the truth and they study
they'll see that if they take an
analytical scientific approach Islam is
based on reason and it calls you to
think and ponder when they think and
ponder and reflect over to evidence they
come to the same conclusion eyes or 1.5
billion this is from the Creator so God
is saying to fast so we want to know how
is the fast some people say ok do I just
give up you know some some some of the
things that I love of food maybe I'll
just drink some water during the day
smoke some cigarettes you know I mean
I've known people that they'll give up
food and drink but then they'll still
smoke all day so that is have you have
you know about this they'll sit do it
and nicotine do you violated your fast I
talk to us about what you can and can't
do well fasting in the technical term
like we mentioned in the first segment
is abstaining in sac abstaining
abstaining from eating drinking and all
other things which are considered to be
in validators are fast according to the
law of Islam and your sexual desire
which is included in there from the odd
and tell sunset with the intention of
worshipping Allah subhanAllah so before
the Sun breaks right what can you do now
before then can you can you go ahead and
get some food into your system talk to
us from there in the start before the
sunset know before the day the day break
for the dawn breaks before dawn before
fudge
it you can drink of course rasoolallah
allah salam established for us the
sunnah of having the early morning meal
which comes before failure which we
cause who also hope both words are
correct and he actually said that as a
house in nephi sahari Baraka wake up and
had that early morning meal because
there is a blessing in it and like I
mentioned it really distinguishes us
from the fastening of the people of the
book he was about don't eat at early
morning meal and it helps you throughout
the day even if you wake up to take a
drink of water and eat a sufficient
before done now add done the time of a
little fetch when the break of day
alight you know when the hydrological
cycle as what the white red and the
black thread are the you're able to
distinguish them from one another then
you abstain but now you must have
formulating an intention we fall down
because intention is one of the pillars
of fastening inclusion intention having
the intention to the extent that
schoolers some of the drawers actually
they say that let's say that you're
fasting and in a way you decided my
intention to break your fast like you
know you're getting you cannot fast
anymore and in your heart you said you
know what as soon as I get water on a
minute let's see that you arrived at the
restaurant and you change your mind your
fasting is invalid because the intention
is no longer there of course there is
you know a way to deal with that but
that person has to make up that day and
even so he should not eat the rest of
the day because you are so the intention
you must have the intention before dawn
now the scholars debated whether you
need to have an intention for each
single day or one intention is
sufficient for the whole month of
Ramadan the consensus or the majority of
the jurors they say that an intention is
necessary for each single day and the
intention is that the thought you needed
just a thought now as how they define
intention say osmolality either a fair
shake that in your heart you the fact
that you broke your fast as you're
eating you're thinking about tomorrow is
another view from Allah that's already
been sufficient so you so you have the
intention that I'm going to please my
Creator and fasting for him you got it
you can't like okay check look at this
shape you can't now or many people they
won't even pray let's say they they
let's say they'll get up and eat but I
guy said come on let's go pray fudger I
got look at you like you're crazy you
can't separate the two right well what
we gotta look at this in a very smart
way yeah i navigate our way you see
fasting will come in your skill as a nap
in the day of resurrection abandoning
your salah if you're not doing it in a
way that takes you out of the fold of
Islam then it comes in the scale of your
say you had your babies in a way out of
the good hour don't tell somebody
because you're not praying you cannot
fast as a matter of fact please go ahead
and fast and if you can gradually get
that person can either way I'm not
judging a person now but I'm trying to
get him to be better a better muslim but
if you tell him you're not playing gone
fast you lost you know hopefully shot
some who build up that they'll start
praying yes and and we know that when we
repent let's say that this person is
won't repent in a year or two yeah his
fasting will be carried on a lot more
forgiving him for abandoning the solar
correct so that means we should not
totally dismiss the person and turn him
away the fact that he's doing the
fasting and hamdulillah this is good you
know a lot of us are coming back from
jahiliyyah yeah Eddie a lot of Muslims
are coming they don't even know that
abandonment sola can take it out of the
fold of Islam so we need to deal with
the people in our way
you keep them olivia munn give them the
opportunity but yes I mean what you're
saying is right I mean if you do not
pray and then you're fasting in fact if
you if you if you think about it a
prophet sallal send them mention that
the first thing that you will be asked
about in the deep resurrection is so low
how do you know and it look at this now
if the Salah is valid in a loss of
hyerollah will look at the rest of your
needs that's the number one thing yes
yeah and guess what that number one
thing is notarization for the rest of
that if that would include fasting so
technically what we're saying also is
absolutely correct and write that the
fasting is no good if that person dies
neglecting and abandoning the Salah but
again from at our perspective we look at
it in a different way so being gentle
and kind and having with the PA yeah
absolutely so okay so now so to give
people kind of a timeline here you wake
up with the right intention right before
fire breaks in so you eat a little bit
and then you pray fudger and then your
day goes on food drink relations with
the wife no no not someone said look
there's a true story the the the
brothers you know sent the woman to the
store to get themselves a bia meet you
know for the fast she said what do you
are you must have no it's for my
boyfriend I was I would live in LA no
this wife right no boyfriend and
girlfriend is this level of the time go
ahead tell us very quickly yes that came
last Ramadan to my mosque invested in
Abu Bakr in the garage yeah I'm guess
she's a muslin sister yeah and she is
marrying a non-muslim and guess what
she's coming to pay zakat with it you
know the second yeah I at the end of the
month for her and her husband uh-huh
imagine this he's a Muslim woman who's
marrying I mean it's not really married
in this area so she's really committing
adultery but she is coming to pay zakat
who thought the decade and asking people
pay again the technology and it should
be going out in
and food yeah but I asked her sister
subhanAllah you're coming to do this
meanwhile you two are eating with an an
allophone this man is not a Muslim and
she said well I i wanna fulfilled you
know and i told her about this guy who
has to be Muslim for you to be married
when he cannot imagine idiot I just
wanted it he rose to power this this man
I accepted look at this woman and he
gives us so much about you she's having
twins a cabin filter for you she will
receive you and here you are you are the
reason for her hell what do you want me
to do you believe in one God yeah I
believe in one God you believe that
Muhammad is ms yes he actually accepted
it took that he had a mush and we got
there married Marshall Emma Khalifa
though I just wanted this out of this
world that you know yeah it's sometimes
I'm telling you a lot of also coming
back from Gideon Austin so but look
clinging to one this sister I'm sure
back home I think she's from Tajikistan
Uzbekistan one of these extraction
countries where they were really derived
from knowledge but you know something
that one if this is the right for one
thing one thing yeah look come on is a
kind of it yeah meanwhile she's
violating a whole she's basically was
out of the full of Islam adding on
Muslim I'm just gonna turn up Maggie Bob
a Muslim man we know this for a fact and
any woman who does it good out of the
fall of Islam know if she's if she knows
it yeah if she knows what she didn't
know but look her clinging to that
little thing got her you know fix
amazing he cannot imagine she was so
excited she called their family back
home and that was an interesting mr.
amazing amazing yes lost Ramallah and he
submitted that's a beautiful thing he
decided to worship the crater not his
Christian became a Muslim yeah it's a
pas la la look at her man kidding about
you yeah he believes that she should pay
solid offer you that you you you you're
in good health and oh look at this woman
you know according to her religion which
she is relying on to save you you are
the reason for her
going to hell for eternity come on man I
mean you can't you can't be selfish what
do you want do you believe in one God
and then XP removes a lot is are you
willing to submit and you know I know
that you may not be able to completely
apply everything and implement
everything but are you willing please
are you willing just just the will the
intention he said yes I am and it ok
Shahada and we got them married Islam is
the natural way it makes sense it makes
sense when it's explained and we'll be
right back with more to make sense of it
more here on the Dean show this simple
to understand Islam means submission
look at the word submission not to
yourself not to your desires not to
anyone or anything because at the end of
the day you get something you always
want more you get some weed you want
more you get some drugs you want harder
drugs you get a girl you want a nicer
girl you get a car you want a nicer car
get out on a nicer house we've got so
many precious by enslaving yourself
worshiping God loving God but submission
to the one who created you and by what
you've been going and seeking his
pleasure you get pleased and you can't
okay then Cobus you back here on the D
show with sheikh karim and we're talking
about one of the pillars of islam the
way of life of all the messengers of god
jesus did islam abraham did islam all
the messengers at the crater our maker
the maker of this whole universe and
everything in it this is the natural way
worship the Creator not his creation
they all prayed to god they gave charity
in God's name to the poor they fasted so
they can build this God consciousness
and you talked about the fasting you
know it being a time now that you're
developing the spiritual side it's like
it's like a training for your soul right
we don't want to miss out on it so we
want to do it the right way you get up
in the morning and now we talked about
having the right intention eating a
little bit praying the fudge you're
praying the rest of the prayers right
that was one who got four more and then
at the end what what it's really simple
you can't eat food or drink relations
with your wife no boyfriend girlfriends
in Islam and what else can you and can't
do what what else is there is there
anything
well I think it is a big piece of our
fasting which is having a good character
good character oh that's really
important can be cursing absolute lying
that is where the prophet sallallahu
wasallam statesville hadith Oba sorry
mates allahumma cm he led to another
Shobha emulate set up a new guinea he
Allah tawba so it may be somebody who
fasts and although he gets out of his
fasting is a character is I'm sorry
hunger and thirst and maybe somebody who
placed ahead with every night or p.m.
every night and all what he gets
tiresome backbiting all day in your
first time equals he wasted in here and
even even if you're attacked as a
fasting person look at the elite ibyo a
little a pillow under my head and I lost
open only 1i silly LeBron senses even if
somebody finds you if somebody acts with
you in an ignorant way yells at you tell
him I'm pasty I'm fasting twice and you
know so don't argue back know so so okay
so no I mean you should be doing this
anyway curtsying the tongue that you
know praises Allah shouldn't be cursing
with this tongue right you know I again
I always take this back to how we could
you get about ourselves about our Dean
you know the culture would we were
brought up a person in Ramadan would get
so upset and mad happy when I'm fasting
you yells at you and then he's so mad
and when you asked him the reason why
Alou said I'm sorry I'm fasting because
you're fasting you're not supposed to do
that though I actually using fasting as
an executor to do that fasting again
like i said is getting a handle on
yourself controlling your tongue control
listen three things that you you must
you must pay attention to either a meal
time and then when you do anything when
you look when you act then remember
allah subhana allah is watching hope
neither Allah healing well either filter
hablen when you use the tongue remember
allah hears you look at this now this is
the area where you really excel with
your fasting
and when you think about something in
your chest remember Allah knows what
you're thinking about if you manage to
defeat these three areas and purify them
purify your act that's when you do
something remember that Allah has
looking at you when you do it whatever
it is no will you speak remember the
words will give her the final time so
watch and even when you think because
here in America and Milan is coming in
the summer this year as you know and you
know what he will do here in the summer
it's crazy you you think your eyes are
just coming in the airport man you can
keep your eye of this you gonna get
everything is a first look down this is
crazy and even sometimes you just
wishing to be blind or something uh in a
way God your chest not your chest that's
what you need to do in order to win the
forgiveness of so standing for food but
all these other you should come out of
Roma down with a better character you
can't be watching pornography you know
killing time as they say backbiting
doing these evil things that even if it
wasn't on my dad especially Ramadan now
but you should be away from this totally
let me remind the viewers in closing and
I know you have to close the episode
here is remember this leave yours
brothers and sisters in his land jibreel
alehissalaam the trustworthy of the
heavens and muhammad sallallahu are you
sellin the trustworthy of earth they
need one against a person who gets to
live through ramadan and he comes out of
it Unforgiven famous hadith any Holly G
bill Russell's lala land said I mean and
in three lines are officially tell me
how happy I oh then later he explained
and he said G&A dois a loser may he lose
may lose someone whom Allah subhana
Allah grants him the opportunity live
for Ramadan and he comes out of it and
forgiving and I said any interest some
of the brothers we all seek her
forgiveness always the opportunity
people can see you and let's talk about
it yeah that's so
goddess the goddess TV every day
actually we come in Ramadan answer
questions www goddess TV TV and Islam he
won a TV to thank whoa cool channels now
okay so people can look you up there
shake thank you very much may the crater
that have enough reward you for being
with us and helping educate the people
thank you yeah and thank you for tuning
in for another episode of the Dean show
Ramadan and you heard the shakes say it
that look at the end we don't want to be
losers we want to be winners because
this life is short dad judgment is close
and we're going to be just for
everything we did in this life this life
is a test we're going to die and then at
the end hell fire or paradise ramadan is
here and we all have things that we can
improve on make sure that we're
committed to praying five times a day
minimum modesty is something that's so
important Islam we have to work on that
for many of our sisters and the brothers
character development all of us need a
dose of that language should be watch
what we say not just with standing from
food but all of these different curse
words are coming out of their mouths
everything in Islam makes sense and it's
telling us to be the best human beings
that we can be because our Creator our
maker that's what he wants from us so we
can be the best in this life and have
the best in the hereafter and if you
want to learn more call us a 1 866 to
islam remember this month is the month
of the Quran so connect with your
Creator through the Quran learn acquired
knowledge so you can have peace peace
with your Creator peace within yourself
and then you'll be committed committed
to serving your Creator in the best way
so you can get the best place Curtis
we'll see you next time until then peace
be with you
growing up in America Eddie lived the
American dream he achieved it all before
the age of 30 money cars but beneath the
surface something didn't feel after
achieving everything he ever designed
Eddie turned his back and walked away
from it all and took his life in a whole
new direction let us take you on his
journey